each year over 93 million tons of onions
are harvested globally with the
integration of Advanced Technologies the
efficiency and quality of onions are
ensured from Harvest through to
packaging typically grown from seeds
sets or transplants the cultivation
process requires careful management of
soil water and Pest Control to maximize
yield once the onion tops fall and begin
drying it signals that they're ready for
harvesting mechanical onion Harvesters
are impressive machines capable of
uprooting cleaning and collecting onions
in One Sweep across the
field equipped with Digger blades these
machines slice through the soil lifting
onions to the surface while minimizing
damage and keeping the roots intact
Conveyor Systems then transport the
onions gently removing excess soil and
debris cleaning mechanisms like brushes
and air blowers further clean the onions
before placing them into large storage
bins or trailers connected to the
Harvester these bins hold large
quantities enabling continuous operation
before requiring unloading the use of
such machines significantly boosts
efficiency allowing Farmers to harvest
large Fields quickly while reducing
manual labor key to preserving onion
quality and freshness by minimizing
spoilage risk
once harvested onions are moved to
processing facilities upon arrival they
are unloaded into large receiving bins
before being transferred onto conveyor
belts for an initial cleaning phase this
phase involves removing soil debris and
loose skins aided by conveyor belts
designed with perforations that allow
debris to fall through while onions
remain on top high pressure air blowers
and rotating brushes complement the
cleaning process ensuring the onions are
as clean as possible before further
processing following the cleaning onions
are sorted and graded automated machines
equipped with Optical sensors categorize
onions based on size shape and quality
these systems detect imperfections and
separate onions that don't meet quality
standards this precise sorting
guarantees uniformity in the final
product and identifies onions suited for
different processing purposes such as
dehydration or
frying Conveyor Systems play a crucial
role in onion processing facilities
ensuring efficient continuous movement
from arrival to
packaging automating these processes
streamlines operations reduces manual
labor and maintains consistent quality
at every production stage this use of
Technology ensures that onions move
seamlessly from the field to the factory
ultimately delivering high quality
products to consumers
worldwide AI enhanced sorting systems
have revolutionized onion processing
these systems use Advanced Optical
scanners cameras and machine learning
algorithms to sort onions accurately and
quickly conveyor belts with individual
compartments and precise sorting
mechanisms ensure each onion follows the
correct path optimizing both efficiency
and product
quality this integration of Agriculture
and artificial intell elligence
represents the future of food production
where efficiency and precision are
Paramount the packaging process for
onions is complex involving different
methods and Advanced Machinery to ensure
efficiency and product quality bulk
packaging uses mesh or burlap bags for
wholesale while smaller consumer
packages typically use mesh or plastic
bags vacuum sealed bags or pre-cut
onions in plastic containers provide
added convenience and extended shelf
life automated Machinery including
bagging sealing and labeling systems
streamlines packaging with conveyor
belts transporting onions through each
stage of the process from cleaning and
sorting to final packing and
distribution large facilities may even
use automated guided Vehicles AGS to
transport packaged onions to various
areas or loading docks further enhancing
operational efficiency and maintaining
product
quality for industrial scale onion
peeling Innovative technology is
essential traditional manual peeling is
labor intensive and time consuming
making it impractical for large scale
production mechanical peelers use
abrasive surfaces or rotating blades to
remove onion skins minimizing damage to
the layers underneath these machines are
adjustable to accommodate various onion
sizes and varieties ensuring consistent
results
some food processing facilities take
onions through peeling washing and
cutting processes to create convenient
ready to use products this
transformation caters to Consumer needs
for pre-prepared onions saves time in
home kitchens and ensures uniformity in
cooking and flavor distribution
additionally processed onions such as
diced or sliced versions offer a longer
shelf life through washing and vacuum
sealing techniques these readyto use
products are popular in the food service
industry where efficiency and
consistency are crucial as well as in
homes for preparing soups stews sauces
salads and more common products include
diced onions sliced onions for cooking
onion rings as appetizers and onion soup
mixes for added
flavor processed onion products are
packaged in ways that ensure freshness
and convenience while meeting Market
demands common options include
resealable plastic bags with Ziplock
seals cardboard boxes for dehydrated
onions and vacuum sealed pouches for
products like frozen diced onions or
onion rings automated Machinery is used
to efficiently handle and package
delicate products such as crispy onions
using heat or ultrasonic sealing
techniques to secure the
packages this Machinery also takes care
of labeling date coding and Quality
Inspection ensuring that only top
quality products reach the market
Market the large scale production of
onions is a highly coordinated process
with Advanced Technologies integrated
into every stage from harvesting to
packaging mechanized Harvesters
automated sorting systems and
specialized packaging Machinery ensure
efficient operations while delivering
highquality onion products to Consumers
worldwide AS Global demand for onions
Rises continued Innovation is crucial to
meeting Market needs sustainably
[Music]